on august 10 2015 google's founders
larry page and sergey brin announced
that they would be stepping away from
google's day-to-day operations at the
time it seemed like the two were simply
stepping back to focus on philanthropy
humanitarian issues and other companies
you know the regular tech billionaire
stuff but since they stepped down both
of them basically fell off the face of
the planet we've only seen a handful of
public appearances if that and it's
almost as if sandra piche was google's
founder
after all sunder is just as popular as
larry page and twice as popular sergey
brin according to google trends so what
happened to google's founders and where
are they today
well starting off if we take a look at
sergey brin and larry page's history at
google we'll see that they never really
chased the spotlight going back to 1998
larry page was originally the ceo of
google when the company was started but
it was clear that neither larry page nor
sergey brin were particularly great
executives in 2001 for instance larry
wanted to fire all the project managers
at google he believed that engineers
should be left their own devices to
produce the best results and that
pressure from management simply stifled
their work so he thought that removing
management altogether was a great idea
while that might work in an ideal world
this was obviously not a realistic
decision especially for a startup which
needed to be precise accurate and
focused after receiving a lot of
backlash for this idea though larry
understood his shortcomings when it came
to running a business and gave up his
position as ceo
it wasn't some crazy falling out like we
so often see though
larry did not leave the company like
steve jobs or jack dorsey mary actually
became really good friends with the new
ceo eric schmidt
in fact i would even argue that larry is
better friends with eric today than his
co-founder sergey eric served as ceo for
a full 10 years until he himself stepped
back stating that day-to-day adult
supervision is no longer needed larry
would become ceo once again in 2011.
this did not last long as he would step
back in 2015. the reason i bring up the
story is to showcase that during larry
and sergey's active involvement with
google larry was ceo for less than half
the time and sergey was never ceo
this is in stark contrast to basically
every other company founder who loves to
have maximum control and be at the
center of attention i mean given that
they founded the company i don't blame
them but this was clearly not the case
with google's founders they never chased
the spotlight while they were at google
so it makes sense that they didn't chase
the spotlight after leaving google
either
aside from being happy with working in
the background both sergey brin and
larry page are extremely private people
neither of them really have any social
media presence they don't have publicly
known facebook twitter instagram or
youtube accounts sergey brin even
suggested that him working on google
plus was probably a mistake because he's
not a very social person
so we won't be seeing random dogecoin
pumps because of a tweet from sergey but
their efforts for privacy stretch way
further than simply avoiding social
media for instance we don't even know
who larry's kids are
we know he had a son in 2009 but we
don't know his name and we've never even
seen a picture of him
in 2011 larry revealed that he had
another child but we don't even know the
gender of this child
it's honestly quite impressive that
larry has been able to hide this
information from the press for so long
at the same time though i bet a lot of
you guys think that this is quite ironic
given that google is infamous for
invading users privacy
but honestly i don't think larry nor
sergey really wanted google to go in
that direction in the first place
and that brings me into my next point
which is that the two lost control of
google
this isn't anything new within the
business world
as companies grow larger and larger
shareholders and investors have a more
significant say in the future of the
company usually the interests of the
shareholders and executives are aligned
though for the most part the primary
goal of executives and shareholders is
to simply grow the company's reach as
much as possible and maximize profit
slash shareholder value
this is the same case with google
shareholders but the problem is that
this is not really the founder's goal
during the 2000s larry and sergey bended
to the shareholders wishes as they
agreed that establishing financial
stability was a top priority however as
google became a dominant player and
started pulling in massive profits year
after year larry and sergey wanted to
focus on something more meaningful they
wanted to focus on experimentation
research and innovation instead of just
increasing profits year after year after
year
in may of 2013 larry would reveal his
long-term vision for google and this
would make it clear that larry and the
shareholders did not agree whatsoever
larry wanted to create something called
google island as the name suggests larry
wanted google to operate as if it was an
island this meant cutting out corporate
shareholder and government interests i'm
not sure how larry expected the public
to react
maybe he thought that they would support
his goal of focusing on innovation over
profits but the public basically just
laughed at him the press ran several
papers suggesting that this was just for
the evidence that tech billionaires were
completely disconnected from reality
and shareholders just wrote off google
island as some ludicrous nerd fantasy
the fact that the public ridiculed the
idea made it evident that neither larry
or sergey really had control over google
anymore now technically they still own
51 percent of the voting shares so they
could technically do whatever they
wanted but doing something that your
shareholders relented would still not be
that good of an idea and this lack of
control probably just pushed them to
leave the company
objective issues regarding control and
the company's future weren't the only
things that played the duo's leadership
though another major factor pushing the
two to leave public life was their
personal issues in 2012 larry page would
be struck by vocal cord paralysis larry
had actually been dealing with vocal
cord issues for the entirety of his life
but the situation became especially bad
starting in 2012 his voice would become
more and more hoarse and quiet and larry
would begin avoiding earnings calls
speaking events conferences and of
course the media
in the meantime sergey would undergo his
own pr nightmare
in 2014 it would be revealed that sergey
brin had been having an affair with the
google employee named amanda rosenberg
at the time he was married to ann
watcheski who you may know as the
founder of 23andme to make things worse
and sister susan is the ceo of youtube
so i would assume the executive meetings
at google were quite awkward after that
larry page was also not amused
whatsoever about the situation
larry had been friends with sergey since
college and he saw sergey's relationship
with anne grow first hand
this affair was completely unexpected
for larry and he basically started
shouting sergey ever since
larry stopped talking to sergey and it
doesn't seem like larry ever forgave
sergey fortunately for sergey he had a
large enough take in google that he
couldn't be ousted but i'd imagine that
public events were embarrassing to
attend and this was likely a major
factor driving sergey out of the
public's view
i think we'd agree that all the reasons
we outlined thus far are valid reasons
to avoid the spotlight but i think the
biggest reason sergey and larry have
shied away from the public is that
google's original vision has been lost
if you haven't noticed yet larry and
sergey never aimed to build a massive
tech giant their vision was always to
build a research company that was run by
engineers just think about the projects
that these two are most excited about
one of the projects that larry was most
excited about was google self-driving
car project similarly one of the
projects that circuit was most excited
about was google glass though both of
these projects have more or less just
been massive money pits it seems like
their passion has always lied in
google's moonshot factory for them it's
never been about maximizing revenue from
ads or dominating various sectors of the
market
but as we touched on it that's what
google has turned into google is more
bureaucratic profit hungry and
monopolistic than ever before
google used to consistently rank as the
top place to work year after year
but at the end of 2019 google actually
dropped out of the top 10 places to work
now i still personally think that
google's overall impact on the world is
overwhelmingly positive but google is by
no means perfect google's original motto
was don't be evil
and i'm not sure if larry and sergey
still believe that that's still
completely true with google
the duo have awarded answering questions
about google stance in regards to
privacy monopolies and google's various
questionable decisions if they come out
of your shell however it's just a matter
of time until a reporter asks them about
their thoughts on google's business
practices
they've never been interested in that
side of the business and likely prefer
that senator pichai and the other
executives deal with that instead
but that still leaves a question what
have larry and sergey been up to since
they left google well larry has been
able to focus his time on flying cars
over the past couple of years he
invested into multiple flying car
companies and he seems pretty optimistic
about the future of flying taxis reports
also suggest that larry has been
spending large amounts of time on his
private caribbean island as for sergey
we really don't know much about what
he's been up to
in january of 2017 sergey made a
surprise appearance at a protest against
trump's immigration order at the san
francisco airport and there are reports
suggesting that sergey is working on
some sort of sky yacht for 100 million
dollars but that's pretty much it for
sergey the two still hold 51 of the
voting shares of alphabet though
so they could technically return to the
company and change the direction if they
want it
now of course they can't implement
something as crazy as google island but
they could definitely revise google
stands on privacy or its workplace
environment however the two just sold 1
billion worth of stock which was their
first stock sale since 2017
so it seems like the two are going to
just let google do its own thing for the
best or the worst do you guys think
sergey and larry will come back to
google just like steve jobs or michael
dell comment that down below
also drop a like if you're grateful that
they founded google
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you